Well,
you know,
I have a blog and I've actually written
quite a bit on this because you know,
if the US capital markets in terms of
sophistication or a 10,
China's a two.
Okay.
So China's got a long way to in the
capital markets in China.
Like when I went to Wall Street in 1973,
they were about as developed as that
was.
Okay.
So you know,
that's a,
that's a negative in one sense,
but I think that China could learn a lot
from what's happened over the list of
the last 10 days,
two years,
whatever you want to,
whatever timeframe you want to pick.
Because the US market has gotten so
sophisticated,
so big,
so complicated and you know,
now everybody's scratching their head
and saying,
hey,
how do we regulate this?
How do we control it?
How do we prevent,
prevent this from happening again?
This gives China a gigantic opportunity
to really look at all this would have
everybody's gonna be analyzing and
studying about this whole crisis and
then to think to themselves about how
they then go about the process of taking
their capital markets up the curve.
So you know,
in many ways being the second or the
last kid on the block is a lot of times
an advantage because you get to kind of
see where everybody else has gone
through and kind of learn from their
experience.
And I think that the child would be well
served to really look very,
very hard and really try to understand
how this all happened and then to think
about in the context of China and what
that means for how China's capital
market.